>>Narrator: For centuries,
the Choctaw Indians
of Mississippi have celebrated
their culture in games and dances.
>>Group: [sings]
>>Narrator: Now the youngest
generation is learning
about their tribe's culture
and sharing their discoveries
with a global audience through
the International Education
and Resource Network's
First Peoples Project.
Indigenous people from
five continents participate
in this cultural exchange.
>>Student: [speaks Choctaw]
>>Man: Our ancestors were praising
the animals that provided food and...
>>Narrator: Students conduct research
into their own unique heritage.
They then write stories, draw
pictures and take photographs.
>>Student: We're going to
send this digital picture
to the [inaudible] group in Thailand.
What'll we write?
First a greeting and then
we're going to tell them
about the picture that
we're sending them.
>>Narrator: The artwork is displayed
on the First Peoples Project Web
site, and it's also exchanged
by mail each year with
other project schools.
>>Student: This is the kind of
painting done by Albert Lewis.
He's in fifth grade, and I
reckon the colors is well done.
>>Bob: We display the
artwork and different teachers
in schools may develop their
own curriculum activities,
because we have this treasure
that's come in once a year.
>>Student: They live
in houses like these.
They don't have very much
possessions and they sleep on mats
and don't have a lot of furniture,
and this is -- they
have small tables.
>>Narrator: The Mississippi
band of Choctaw Indians,
which operates the largest and most
tech-savvy reservation school systems
in the country has participated in
the First Peoples Project since 1995.
>>Student: Let's do that one.
>>Narrator: This year, the First
Peoples Project theme is "pastimes,"
and for the Choctaw,
that means stickball.
America's first field sport, it was
called "the little brother of war"
and traditionally played to settle
disputes among rival factions.
The rules are simple in
this rough-and-tumble game:
Carry or throw the ball
downfield using your sticks,
then bounce it off the
other team's goalpost.
>>Jason: You've got to be strong
body, mind and your spirit.
You've just got to be all toughened.
If not, you're going to get
hurt once you start playing.
>>Narrator: In addition
to the art exchange,
the First Peoples Project has
a humanitarian aid component,
an effort that began
several years ago,
when Choctaw students
were watching a videotape
that showed the stark conditions
of a project school in Thailand.
>>Woman: You can see all
-- what do you call --
the holes that the wind can seep in.
It's very cold in the night, and
the teacher said one of the things
that they need a lot is blankets
to help keep the cold away.
>>Bob: Some students that were
watching the film at the time says,
"We've got plenty of blankets.
Can we just send them some blankets?"
and at the same time the
kids in Zuni, New Mexico,
were seeing the film,
and they just happened
to say basically the same
thing: "Well, we make blankets.
We have blankets.
Can we send them some blankets?"
>>Narrator: So the students
launched a humanitarian effort
that is still going strong today.
>>Student: So we made Christmas
cards for Thailand to raise money,
and we gave them a generator.
>>Woman: That's great.
What did you think about that?
>>Student: I thought
it was kind of nice.
>>Narrator: So far, the tribe
has raised money to buy blankets,
flooring and a generator and
fund a teacher's aide position
and several student scholarships
for the Thailand school.
>>Teacher: Look this way.
>>Narrator: While the
humanitarian efforts
and the art exchanges connect
students to their peers
around the globe, the process
of researching their own
culture has given these students
and even greater reward: a chance
to connect with their elders.
>>Student: What's your
favorite Choctaw dance?
>>Man: Snake Dance, because you
maneuver to the right, to the left,
and you just wiggle around,
and that's the way life is.
Life is not always straight road,
and that's what the Snake
Dance reminds me of.
>>Group: [sings]
>>Bob: The importance of this project
has been it prods us to research
and get the kids working in areas
that are significant here at home,
communicating more with their elders.
>>Student: When did
you start chanting?
>>Man: I was with John Levi Bell.
You ever heard of John Levi Bell?
>>Bob: Researching culture, learning
how to research through the Internet
and coming up with the information,
going through the process,
the learning process.
>>I don't want kids to forget
about traditional dancing
or traditional cooking or
speaking their own language,
and maybe I can influence or somebody
else can influence these kids
that we need to keep our
tradition and our culture alive.
>>Group: [sings]
>>Man: Can you all speak Choctaw?
>>Student: A little bit.
>>Man: And even if you just can say
a few words in Choctaw, that's okay.
Anything you want to
learn, you can learn.
We're all supposed to learn
from each other as we go along,
because I can learn from you.
I'm learning something from you
about that humanitarian
-- I didn't know that.
I learned something from you.
I hope you learn something from me.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.